welcome everybody to the h3 podcast live
today's episode is sponsored by stitch
fix Dollar Shave Club and the black tux
today's guest is the mega not just he's
not a superstar he's a megastar ninja
the twitch streamer and pro gamer and
fortnight phenomenon
many of you probably know who ninja is
but for those of you who don't know let
me give you some numbers to kind of put
in perspective what we're dealing with
here so I was checking ok well he's a
twitch streamer let's start there at the
at the beginning of the year he had a
just under a million subscribers that
was just a few short months ago and a
million subscribers on twitch makes him
one of the biggest channels on twitch
she was a big deal
fast forward to today since that moment
he's up over 6 million subscribers on
twitch the biggest channel on twitch by
far now he's broken all the streaming
records he first broke the streaming
record what for the most concurrent
viewers at one time when he played with
the Drake
yes Drake mr. uh hot whatever you guys
know drink hey mister yeah exactly
shed the sweater I love Jake he's the
greatest so jealous I get to sit across
from someone who's played with Drake
that sounds bad
I like I like him for it I just have him
on to get to Drake I'm thinking about
Trane I lost my dream he he broke the
record one who's playing with Drake the
previous record was dr. disrespect when
he came back from his break he had like
three hundred thirty eight hundred
thousand concurrent viewers which was
enormous
so when Nietzsche blasts on the scene
with Drake they get six hundred thousand
concurrent viewers this is unbelievable
four alive people sitting there watching
like okay and then he broke his own
record again this last weekend when he
was in Vegas putting on some really cool
event that I want to talk about later
with him but that event broke his
own record was 660,000 live viewers his
YouTube channel which is highlights of
his Twitter stream is unbelievable he
posts a highlight every day and these
are getting like 4 to 7 million views
every day in the past month in the past
30 days on YouTube he's gained 3.2
million new subscribers and has 200
million views in the past month in the
past 30 days I've never seen anything
like it
it's unbelievable it's exciting it's
cool to see that that somebody could
take it this far could blow up this much
it's it's those numbers like don't make
sense I've never seen like never seen
anything like it
3.2 million news today he's streaming
with Drake was the day we did our live
show at the improv and we streamed it
really I'm pretty sure that wasn't what
was happening and we were like wow that
was great it was so much fun and then
after the show well apparently there was
something huge going on nobody cared
about no not shitty live show anyway
yeah I remember like just that that was
the first time I heard about him feel
like if you thought that was crazy
you're 20,000 views I know that's got a
dude we used we could pull like 10 to
30,000 outside and those were like top
numbers for the longest time 30,000 was
like top top dog in it this guy now come
just will casually stream with over a
hundred thousand I didn't think it would
be possible
it's incredible it's super exciting and
I'm super happy for him to because he's
a nice sweet genuine guy he's been in
the game for a long time he's been a pro
gamer for ten years okay so this isn't
some overnight the guy's been grinding
heart and he deserves his success he's a
sweet guy he's an interesting guy super
excited to talk to him I hope you guys
are excited to watch so we are just
gonna hop off we're gonna go grab him
he's coming in soon so stay tuned we'll
be back shortly with your boy ninja so
do not go away god bless you
appreciate you you're the best I love
you dad cut me off because I don't stop
know how to stuff
what up pimps we've got the man here
yeah boy ninja aka Tyler Blevins yes
let's play where's the origin of beloved
uh I get that everyone so mama it's like
Welsh my mother yeah well [ __ ] means a
little wolf oh oh yeah man that's
wonderful they're cool
yeah I really said maybe that's to be my
gamertag instead or a little wolf you
know so we were in showing you before
you came in just talking about all the
the unbelief like unprecedented numbers
you've been smashing yeah I've never
seen anyone
I mean I've not been on YouTube the
longest but I've been around for a
little bit now like five years now and
I've never seen in all my time someone
come up so hard yeah so fast right I
mean first of all how has that affected
your life because it seems like you were
popular but in the past four months
according like oh yeah unbelievable
so with how long I've been like
streaming and doing all this content
stuff like that the the massive growth
really hasn't changed much because it's
like in my own way I kind of was like
relevant essentially so it's just really
cool to see to see how girl like looking
at the statistics we're looking at like
numbers and how quickly other people
have grown to and to just kind of like
smash all of that and is amazing it's
mean it's yeah it's unbelievable yeah
and nothing's really changed honestly
the wife and I still have the same
schedule if anything we just kind of I
mean I'm actually trying to stream more
right so that you know there's more
content on like the Instagram clip right
and everything so no I mean coming from
YouTube we had mentioned the intro but
you you have like 3.3 million
subscribers in the past 30 days
yes we're averaging nine every nine days
is a million subscribers about 100 left
had 120 a day and those are just clips
from your twitch streams they are not
yes they are not very rarely will I try
to so like in a live stream if I wanted
to I could do like okay this game is
gonna be tips and tricks so I'll
literally intro it in to the live stream
and then make it more like professional
it's fun fact actually just tested that
for the very first time doing a light
machine gun only this new gun that came
out in four night I was like okay I'm
dude tips and tricks this game right
it's gonna be great like I think I was
thinking 10 million views like in like a
couple of like days like two days and it
actually didn't do the great great it's
not like it's like right in the middle
of kind of where a lot of my just
pre-recorded like ripped content is and
so that actually it was something that
blew my mind
I think people like the authentic
experience yeah
want the real deal they want to see the
crazy [ __ ] that's happening again
exactly and I think that in my opinion I
think a lot a lot of a lot of youtubers
who are trying to like do the the
YouTube live content or their YouTube
content that is planned and they come
over to twitch and it is live it's there
there's like a disconnect there it's ah
you're right
yeah it's hard it's it's a highly
different world and it is this is live
yeah we still suck at it but it's like
the whole lot well we've streamed video
games before yes it can be revoking
brutal like Ustream how long do you
usually stream for oh so the schedule is
like 9:30 is when I'll start in the
morning and then I play until like fours
like six hours 600 hours and then I'll
take a nice three four-hour break with
the wife and dogs and then or family we
have like family nights and stuff like
that too and then come back on around
like seven o'clock central and stream
into like three two in the morning and
then so it's like it's minimum like
twelve hours a day is what we're trying
to be and then I'll sleep for like less
than six hours or seven hours do you
ever get like I would stream for like
five hours a couple times and I was like
I'm [ __ ] done for the week like I'm
not making YouTube videos you hung on in
bed I'm done for the week yeah no it's
it's it's just like I've been doing it
for so long so maybe I built up a
tolerance or something like that an
immunity to like that well it seems like
you really love it oh dude that's that
helps really yeah
and being honestly being good at the
games my worst days where I'm also the
taxed the most are when I'm not doing
well
right and I think that's because you
know it just sucks and also like
mentally draining I'm kind of worried
about I didn't perform today like it's
not okay don't happen often which like
that's a lot of pressure too yes because
you're the best quote-unquote you think
you're the best for tonight I would
never say that no no you have to like
not not like I've never said it because
I think I am but it sounds bad yeah yeah
I know right alright now if you if you
put yourself there like you you're
already kept all downhill
exactly you saying oh I'm saying and
also I can't learn like at that point
it's kind of like oh I'm the best
there's no room for growth right and
that's not well from my point of view
when I watch your videos in your stream
I'm just like what the [ __ ] that's the
gold man but like also that must come
with an extraordinary amount of stress
like you said you streaming and you're
having off days and you feel bad so does
that stress to always perform like so
good how do you cope with that
it really just
it's again like those days don't really
happen too often so I got them really
once every like two or three weeks I'll
have just like a really bad day where
I'll wind only a couple games and you
know it's great actually just having
such a supportive community because I'll
get like a donor or someone in stem it's
just a hey man like nice to know you're
human like that is important you know
and I'll do my best also just be like
hey guys even I suck sometimes like cuz
I'll have you know ten games in a row
where I just died off the start and I'm
like but I'm a very good like at
resetting as well so like sometimes I'll
have like a bad first hour or something
like that and like one time I joked
around and I completely like restarted
my stream essentially I didn't thought
the intro screen back in I laughed I
came downstairs play the song and I was
just like hey guys what's up first game
of the day here we go and I'd up winning
that game we're like 20 kills or
something like that did you make a
conscious effort to get really good at
the game or was it just I mean you're
professional gamer you've been gaming
for what like 10 years oh my entire life
but professionally like seven eight okay
when fortnight came out what was it did
you have kind of a feeling of like this
is gonna be a big game what was your
process of being like I'm gonna be
really good at this game or are you just
good at all games I'm good at all games
and that's just from being a gamer mine
right my entire life yeah it's literally
what I do so and I played a lot when I
was growing up a lot of RPG games you
know the teenage Ninja Turtles legend of
legaia Legend of Dragoon and Final
Fantasy and then halo 1 Goldeneye these
Super Smash Bros I literally played
every game imaginable you know written
dude road rash I don't this amazing man
squeal back dude it was amazing run a
motorcycle and you could like buy and
upgrade your motorcycles and like you
had like you could like whip like you
know with chains like you're the other
guys next to you it was actually super
fun but no yeah playing all those games
just kind of made me you were you were
prepared from all angles yes yes sir d
and also what people don't yet for night
man
it didn't blow up right away by any
means ever no I was I kept my eye on it
I always check out my chat right and
when they're asking you to play a game
or play with someone in the back of my
head I'm always like okay like this
needs to be there's some research on
this and either watch it or you know
watch this guy's content and see if I
could be someone to collab with and
stuff and the game was not being
received well by a lot of top
broadcasters
I was watching that they were
complaining about it oh it's too
cartoony oh it's not fun it's not no
scale it's not and then but when I'm
watching it myself I'm like this this
looks really entertaining they're really
fun so I waited for there was like an AR
update where they like increase the
accuracy or whatever and I was like okay
this is my I kept telling my chat like I
will play it just soon I will play it
soon I will play it soon and then
finally I switched from pub G love the
game was not very good at it in terms of
the shooting is not the difficult part
it's building and that meta kind of grew
over time and I figured that out how
important it was to obviously block
shots from people shooting you and then
once I figure that out I think that's
what I'm missing I'm so bad at the game
yeah the whole fort aspect you know
penis gallery I literally love that ya
know it's building is literally the most
important thing the way that you just
like well good players they'll like
build a whole [ __ ] tower yeah like
jumping and building on it I can't be I
can't get it oh yeah I know that is that
that's the part that really takes a
minute to get down so you'll find that
there aren't that many talented players
like in every game so if you just build
simple little structures you can win
that's enough yeah it is it is but again
if you're gonna run into a Mira
you know another top player that is like
trying actually game lame-o you're dunk
on yeah yeah it's very easy to tell if
somebody's not good I think for
tonight's such an interesting game
because well if you look at if you
compare it to pub G which is just a
pretty simple shooter with a really cool
it's actually super basic it's super
basic it's got a really cool concept and
a cool map yes that concept is basic
yeah and fortnight took it then next
step further by introducing another
element of strategy yeah it went like
Super Saiyan like God like like vulture
and say turned it and real I catch a
game of chess yes it really was
so like the a lot of people are like oh
you know built like pub G requires so
much more skill because you know there's
no building you know and it's like wrong
it's exact opposite like pub G someone
sees you from a mile away with a times
15 scope yeah it can hide in a building
and kill you and have the and be
completely it's not difficult to shoot a
gun and hit somebody like gun skill is
not is never the main reason that
someone's talented at a game it is
literally their decision making like you
know next level stuff what are they
thinking ten steps ahead and pop G you
and not saying the game does obviously
require talent but less of less of it in
my opinion there's a lot less of a skill
gap yes where you can get this good or
as good like with you if you were trying
everything if I try every game and I
don't I a lot of games for me throwing
you know the impulse bombing in aiding
myself 50 feet in the air and trying to
like swag on someone with a noscope like
if I did not do that I only went mega
trihard I'd win like 90% of my games it
really 1,000,000%
I'll and I'll ant a 1 million percent
Elena tilted towers dude like I would
never land there I would try it I would
land in very outskirt and like sides
like I died mainly because I other
messing around too much i under arrest
or entertaining you're not playing
exactly I find that balance yeah and
some days the worst days are when I try
to goof off too soon I don't get wins
and then now I'm trying but now I'm kind
of in my own head and then I'm not gonna
win and then oh yeah weird so we touched
briefly on like how fort net wasn't
really that popular frighten it where he
didn't really come from because I
remember when doctor disrespect was here
yes we asked him about fortnight because
we just had Brendan green the right Bob
G crater on like a week before cool and
it was like fortnight was like this cool
little game that was kind of just riding
the Battle Royale wait up and then all
the Select suddenly it was like the most
popular game in the world who so I mean
I think that it stems from really being
free-to-play right and that's it's kind
of like League of Legends yeah perfect
you literally if you want if you want
this is why I don't know a lot of people
aren't doing it like concept of like
League of Legends kind of did that free
to play in game skin purchases are where
they make the revenue game and it's a
solid game I think what it was someone
very recent we had a conversation with
foreign it does not feel free to play
absolutely not and that is that's
actually shroud it was shroud I was
watching trout stream and he was playing
a game that literally was like a puppy
knockoff completely like 100% and it's
free-to-play yeah and and the comment
that he made was like for Annette does
not feel free to play doesn't and
neither did League and correct that's
why it was so successful
oh yeah everyone recently had a
conversation I mean a lot of people like
if there I mean like taking pictures all
the time in in the airport and like this
one guy his dad was just like like oh
like I gotta buy it I should buy it like
it sounds cool I'm like down-low
it's free it's almost the that's how hmm
it's how we can go viral yeah it's so
accessible you can even compare it to
like basketball or baseball or football
in a way because you don't need to you
just need a ball using you can play yes
it needs to be the same way if the game
ever wants to be comparable on that
level agreed like you cannot like unless
the game is literally God's gift to the
earth like you cannot expect a game a
destiny that's a $60 it's got it's a
huge barrier oh yeah
yes yes especially since Destiny's like
what is actually on everything besides
mobile and stuff like that yeah that
just came out on PC right for two but
yeah ma'am can't expect people to just
buy it's interesting he bucks a lot of
money I think a lot of people are like I
don't want free-to-play games to on the
other hand because they're like I don't
want a bunch of trash and I don't really
access rights right and I don't want to
have to pay for [ __ ] but the way that
they do it is so perfect unoffensive
well they have a they have the single
player you have to pay tip if you want
to yes but totally unnecessary
yeah I mean it's been actually super fun
I thought of dude I loved it
I seen a lot of videos in it I mean it's
great like a tower defense man have you
played it I mess around with it a little
bit I actually try not to because
there's less like there's no delay
there's no jump fatigue on the that
which always when you jump in and you
like it's gonna pollute your it does
like I would jump in the survival one
and it's like instant like I can tell
there was no connection involved
whatsoever like oh my god and I switched
over it's like playing on it's a claw
three up dude halo three yes halo three
man on a LAN to online Xbox Live is
completely night and day so that's funny
mmm-hmm
when I first heard about you when I
first saw you on the radar was when you
had this incredible game with Drake oh
and you guys broke the concurrent views
record right was sick about 600,000 it
was like 650 650 hundred which before
the devious record was like docks
like Greece 30 or something who did
start with for them before before before
it was before T ones come back Tywin's
come back hand before docks it was
someone else I forget who it was I don't
remember
anyways no yes so Tywin smashed it with
uh with his you know League of Legends
unbanned
and then he made that cool Draven
cosplay which is awesome and then he was
like 360 or so I got 300 300 octane back
right 390 thread and 37 I'm insane and
then yeah we sweeper much doubled it
was it was crazy I never seen numbers I
didn't know numbers like that were
positive I didn't either and then you
broke it again this last weekend with
your event in Vegas that I really want
to talk to you about I love to yes
but you you had like 660 what did you
have picked 80 I think was a the numbers
were an hour which is like kind of
unfortunate that they aren't like twitch
I don't know if they can actually
release the exact I think the met no
they're not ready the ability to the
metrics are weird
Oh on something like on my screen right
now I can be on twitch like right now
you could have 25 years 100,000 I have
no idea but I could see ninety-one
someone else can see 92 really yeah it's
people are in and out yeah and with
three L's sorry without our Alice I mean
like it's like a story it's a long game
it's the same thing with League of
Legends actually the viewer dip right so
you start the game up boom your viewer
you literally I promise you like no one
will lose viewers as the game goes on in
one game you will only go up and then
the second the game is over your yeah
you lose about 1050 like I lose like
I'll lose like thirty thousand viewers
and now gain them right back in huh
that's super interesting yeah I mean it
makes sense they probably have [ __ ] to
do waiting for they want to see the wind
right there's a lot of people were like
I mean yeah I don't know what's wrong
like I'm not going to bed till you win
the game we win this game or like win
this game and people they're invested ya
know the drakes it kind of thousand the
event Vegas that what what are what a
sporting events can't live well it's
like a basketball game get who actually
know that damn hook that up I'm curious
I know yeah I think the statistic wise
this is something was released like two
three four years ago something like that
was like the total views of riots
world's event was like 20 mil or 19 mil
or something like that and then like the
Superbowl was at like 60 ml well the
Super Bowl of course that's a tough
figure that stat it was it was the World
Series actually smashed the World Series
didn't completely smashed it the World
Series had nine or something like that
nine that was over the course of the
whole series not just one game what's
the static n uh it was like the world
World Finals for League of Legends was
more than all six or seven games of the
World Series combined yeah all sporting
events except for the
here we go we've got so you've got a
national basketball league gets on
average two million per game two million
views per game yeah okay
now compare that like in a way you're
just a dude playing a game right it's
getting there right oh yeah it's
definitely or when you actually had an
event you had almost 700,000 yes
concurrent it was like a seven-hour
event it was long and and if you compare
it to NBA you've got 20 professional not
even 20 cuz you got the bench you got
the coaches you've got like a hundred
full-time athletes making tens of
millions of dollars right I think it's
funny how when you it's nobody like
we've all been wondering for so long
like when's it gonna get there oh it
dude yeah I mean I think that I'm just
happy that I'm at the forefront of it oh
yeah right you're definitely
spearheading it yeah and I wanna I mean
that's the goal is to obviously never
stop thought it'd be I mean you know ten
years from now someone like let's just
say this is the year 2018 right and I
think it is historic I do think I hope
so man I do think so hope more games
with Drake you know I think we'll be a
couple Mike will be there but I think
it's so funny whenever I see you on an
interview they're always obsessed with
like so you get paid half a million
dollars tell me about that how do you
make so you're just playing games people
give you money it's like it's kind of
annoying and it annoys me because it's
like imagine having LeBron James and be
like so people pay you eighty million
dollars to play game it's frustrate you
just dribble a ball right and you shoot
the ball and they pay you eighty million
yeah it's frustrating I I never I'll
never ever react in a negative way to
yes because it comes from comes from it
and it simply mad about it of course
exactly but sometimes it doesn't
sometimes it seems like it doesn't mean
you like it
exactly listen if you want to be better
than the tens of millions of seven
billion people in the world and be
better than them at something and like
do you think you should get paid like
and and and then hear their response I
never I never have asked or been rude
like that but I'd love to hear what they
say well it's it's not art this
statement is just so stupid cuz we
already are paying people to play games
right Eve way more than your make you
tell me you've seen the meme I'm sure
you have what is where did this this
dude is literally he's on twitch right
it's why it's one of those like a
there's a name for the style of the of
the cartoon joke right but it's like
he's just like chillin Washington's like
hey what do you
right now little bobble he's like oh I'm
watching this guy play video game jeez
that's stupid walks like 10 feet sits on
a couch and turns on the basketball game
or dad I know so you watch someone else
you watch someone else play a game it's
like yes is this dude you've been doing
it for hundreds years but better dude
it's even but that's of thing the live
integration right I was actually just in
an interview I can't talk about it but
like one of the things one of the things
I mentioned was imagine someone being
able to to LeBron streaming whatever you
know Drake being able to literally you
know donate five dollars to interact
with guaranteed question that will be
answered yeah oh I think it was like oh
yeah and not only that like ma'am now
he's okay I think you good we all bonded
over our keys before not only not only
that but you get that you couldn't play
with them right you play the same game
as them where I can get good you have
the resources you just play the [ __ ]
game right it's I don't know it's way
cool
no and I agree and well before I get
ahead of myself I did want to ask like
you had this big game with Drake and it
was it was kind of meteor meteorite
meteorite 'ok that's a wordy or meteoric
meteora it was meteoric and that the
media it was like a thing that they
could latch onto and be like this is a
crazy thing so did anything change for
you after that big game I think that
that kind that's I think that that
literal one match with Drake made it
okay for everyone to play video games
hmm I mean like how many this is
something I've had a conversation with a
lot of people about it's like who who's
bigger than then Drake and in the world
of like social media I couldn't pick a
crazy LeBron James is someone that I
would like right up there you're you
know and then maybe like some crazy
crazy actors but really game well but
literally I was gonna make that
reference but and like what would break
the internet and like kind of kind of
people honestly you know you start over
who's one of the very first famous
people that I played with and like it's
a good place to start it I would think
so and then like about immediately even
even that night alone Travis Scott
messages I saw hey get me in there and
it's just like
you're good to play with right no but
not even that but I think I think so so
this is something that's funny like
Travis actually like drop me in post
maids throughout the game one time and I
was like okay the only reason he did
that is because he knows he must watch
the stream he doesn't follow me or
anything like that but he clearly
watches because he knew that I loved
those grenades it was actually really
cool that's awesome um and yeah no I
think that literally that moment of
playing with Drake made it it everyone
is just like okay I can I can like tweet
about this I can like tell everyone that
hey it is cool the gamer I can play I
play video games too it definitely made
it cool but I feel like even playing
with Obama may not have been crazier it
wouldn't be as dope yeah unless Obama
asks you pass if he was and here's the
thing man if they urge any if they're
actually like interested in the game
then it'll be natural and I'd be like
organic and that's kinda was a trick JP
played all the time it's a fact that
Drake was a fortnight player and a pub
Jeep player or watcher yeah
did people know that before he caught a
game with you no I don't think anyone
knew I mean I don't think anyone knew
about that at all and like when one of
the greatest conversations of that night
was when I I think I asked him was like
so how long you been playing for a night
or whatever say oh yeah I've been
playing for a minute man I've been
watching you for like a while I saw you
win that tournament as just imagine
Drake at home watching you and you don't
even know yeah exactly and do that's the
thing do in no one none of these people
really go out of their way because it's
truly right now it is becoming cooler
and okay and acceptable but people did
not like maybe no one wanted to yeah
you'd like that Oh Drake watch someone
play video games it's like you but if
everyone plays video games come on right
so it's like okay now I do think it's a
genuine think it's historic I don't
think that video gaming professionally
has ever got that level of not not just
publicity but like good publicity right
and you and I to your credit you went on
you did all the interviews you talk to
people and there's a lot of shitty
characters out there and but you were
presentable you were positive you made a
you were a great face thank you I think
I was on it I was so I'm so happy for
you and I was so relieved to see you
talking I was like this is a good this
is the perfect dude for the step thank
you ma'am
yeah thank you ma'am so just
don't stop yeah listen no I know no
intention whatsoever man I mean I've
turned the stream completely into into
be like g-rated man I literally it was
in a conversation earlier like my goal
is to make it like you know your classic
spongebob squarepants we're like the
parents at home can get like a dirty
joke or something like that but the kids
are completely oblivious right I feel
like it's genuine to court if if someone
like that oh yeah it's not like I have
to you know like I don't have to do that
at all and a lot of people who are
famous don't give a [ __ ] and they don't
do that at all yeah like that's
something where it's like oh yeah
absolutely man one parent I think email
me and was just like would really love
if I could you know watch you and not
have to meet the stream and we're just
like it's got it this is like this is it
like we talked about making it
family-friendly and like now it's like
so how did you just cut out cursing were
you cursing a lot before oh yeah I mean
it's it's a gaming thing really it is
and the chart not so it's like of course
and like it's not in my opinion man the
cursing thing is like of course little
kids should be running around dropping
f-bombs or swearing at all you know at
that age and it's simply just because
it's like you don't understand the
meaning behind it there's so many other
things and also other meanings that the
word certain words have but it's not
like I was you know a bad person or
anything like I just swear it was gaming
been involved it in my entire life but
I've been cutting out certain you know
things and phrases that were accepted in
the gaming community and as it becomes
more popular they have to phase out has
it been difficult no easy yep I have my
brother Chris is someone who I really
admire with how he can turn off a you
know he's got and just what's the
perfect word I'm trying to he just he
switches it off you know I mean what he
was a neat he says whatever he wants we
talk about whatever he said nice
impressed oh and then he's a teacher -
he's incredible
right and it'll and it's literally night
and day you're talking like completely
you know and that's something that I'm
trying to like master so how did you and
how did you hook up with Drake ah dude
love this story one of my favorites to
tell literally I am a friend of came up
to me one of my good friends Alex it was
like hey man like there's someone
telling or someone has like your
Instagram posts like are posting your
clips on for tonight on Instagram and
they're getting like 200 300 400
thousand likes every single video that I
need I'm gonna do that right so we
didn't like strike the dude or anything
because I didn't I don't know anything
about Instagram whatsoever so I just had
my account already a while ago I had
like 60,000 followers that I
I love that noise by the lab I mean
something went really doing say no no no
it so started making a lot of Instagram
posts and it just caught fire so fast
and like really quickly I think I had a
million in like less than a couple of
weeks great like the videos were being
you know received very well which is
weird I think there's the hashtags or
how they got anyways that's irrelevant
I'm interested don't know so we made
sure that like my my youtube editor
James he's incredible he helps me with
my Instagram posts we split that like
we'll just throw up a clip every once in
a while but like the hashtags or
something that we literally pretty much
just copied from like other four night
hashtags are famer for Nate this for
night live when it clipped and then we
put those into ours and then they just I
think they enter the system oh yeah it
was literally our first our first our
first four and I clip got like 500,000
Wow only about 50,000 followers nuts
what is the benefit of posting to
Instagram for it litora sides exposure
or it's just exposure man kids like
YouTube like the younger generation from
what and it took I'm kind of kicking
myself in the face not face kicking
myself myself somewhere myself because
you know that I didn't make the
connection when you know I visited my
one of my like cousins in Chicago
Orangeburg in like Michigan or whatever
and his kid was like 10 years old or
something but was on Instagram really
and I didn't know and I was like I'm so
dumb that I didn't think to start making
a lot more Instagram posts but
eventually now obviously started doing
it and that's how I found me literally
Wow connected it was completely natural
a lot of people there's someone who I
want to talk about Bono we thought it
was like oh it was total stage total
stage ever probably pay Drake there's no
way this was like off like Drake would
be interested in getting did like he
would be something like dude he'll give
a [ __ ] alright exactly how much you can
pay this guy milli was good yeah so so
it was super organic and he followed me
my entire chat freaked out so he doesn't
follow that many people in Instagram I
imagine clearly I was weird
really we were streaming and the chat
was like Drake fought how these people
know everyone said she I don't know I'm
so crazy champagne pop ethology shampoo
papi followed you and I was like
champagne papi oh that's Drake oh oh
sprin sit upstairs right told my wife
showed her and she's just like nope
like you got to be kidding me
so falling back and then he reached out
was like let's play oh good that's the
crate not only did he follow you for him
to reach out and be like let's play yeah
we had a huge talk about should we reach
out to him or not and then and something
that I'm always trying I'd try to will
always try to do is like you know I'm
not a I'm like very I'm very not very
Fanny of too many people and that's how
I'm always going to try to just come off
because it's like no one wants to hang
out with a fan and and I mean I was a
fan but like it's super easy when Drake
was also really chill yeah that's super
cool man like immediately he was just
like we're just kicking it you know
gaming that's freaking awesome yeah man
that's so cool guys we're gonna take a
short break we will be right back do not
go away
do not leave Dan cut me off we'll be
right back after this commercial break
see you guys soon thank you to stitch
fix for sponsoring this episode of the H
Street podcast style some of us have it
and some of us don't have it's easy to
tell between the two of us which one
doesn't have it yeah I'm kidding
obviously I look like a hobo
if you don't dress me you're my stitch
fix without you I would be a hobo where
is my fee yeah come on you get you get
your fee I cook for you I clean
sometimes what are you seriously trying
to come at me like oh you don't get
anything out of this no I do other stuff
I can't think of it at the minute you
walk straighter
I walked redder you can get your own
illa klein your own hair as it were at
stitch fix here's the deal with them
some of us cannot dress ourselves let's
be honest about it myself
I need a care you probably do too okay
just because if you want to look good
and you don't it's not possible to
attain there's no time like the
president discovered that Sal you never
knew you had and you can with your own
personalized care from stitch fix six
fix has reinvented how we find and buy
clothing just answer some basic
questions about your size is favorite
styles and budget right from your
laptops Mar
Fenne or tablet you personalized stylus
then springs into action they wrote it
in like bold and I love like this brings
an action as if they're like sleeping
it's bold and italic they like oh [ __ ]
I got a dress someone they've got that
much passionate enthusiasm
that's what ela does when she sees me
walk out of the closet with what I'd use
you to be wearing she'll be like oh my
god it's concert last night you
expressed your interest in new shoes and
then I was up until 2:00 a.m. looking
for shoes for you that's what you can
get from them it's incredible service in
ela may actually I mean you might want
to moonlight for them I think you'd be
really good at it ela might be picking
out your outfit who knows stitch fix
styling fee is only 25 bucks which is
waived if you keep all five items that's
a good deal I don't even pay you of that
and since your personalized stylist uses
only your preference to pick your
clothes you're still in complete control
not gonna take over your life no
commitment required you don't have to
get married to them like I did once your
items arrived try them on and only pay
what you keep don't like something need
another size just send the item back no
questions asked I love that implication
like what's what are you gonna ask like
seriously dude what was a really
something wrong with her or did you just
gain five pounds since we shipped it and
shipping is always free both ways get
your fixed whenever you want or sign up
to receive scheduled shipments the
choice is yours
dan loves stitch fix he's still rocking
that sweater every day it's getting
weird I don't know when he stinks and
I'm like oh Dan's wearing not him but
the sweater cuz he wears it so much I'm
like Oh dance wearing stitch fix again I
made all that up
the stinky part I don't want to defame
Dan he's a clean guy but he does wear
the sweater a lot call to action hurry
to stitch fix calm slash age three get
started right now keep all five items in
your box and you'll get 25% off your
entire purchase that's stitch fix calm
slash h3 stitch fix calm slash h3 get
your
don't care today thank you stitch fix
god bless you
Dollar Shave Club when I say Dollar
Shave Club if the first thing that pops
into your mind is an amazing affordable
shave then I'm about to blow your mind
because there's way more to it than that
how about this Dollar Shave Club has got
more than just razors
they got shampoo Body Wash toothpaste
and of course the best razor I've ever
used that's not even a joke it's the
only razor I'll ever use them doesn't
give me a razor burn it feels and
Clyde's it's a meaty it's weighty it's
got a hefty metal handle that you gotta
feel for yourself but the true hero of
any morning routine is the butter
they've got dr. Carver shave butter this
stuff's amazing like oh oh I'm gonna put
[ __ ] like whipped cream on my face
mm-hmm you met you know that [ __ ] yeah
look you look like a cream pie but this
but it's like it's like actual butter
just goes oh glides across your skin you
have to try it for yourself and with
everything delivered right to your door
that means no more trips to the store
wandering aisles hunting for razors
shampoo toothpaste then having to play a
be a cashier and bag your own items are
you flipping kidding me you expect me to
bag my own items get real that's why
you're going out of business in Dollar
Shave Club has taken over the game for a
mind-blowing experience join Dollar
Shave Club today and for just $5 with
free shipping yeah got six blade
executive razor plus trial size of shave
butter body cleanser and one wipe
Charlies that's a butt wipe and it's
called a one-way because it's just that
effective don't use dry toilet paper and
just smear [ __ ] all over your [ __ ]
this is ineffective and it's disgusting
you going with the wet one and that's
all you need well frankly it's not
necessarily one why because it's a big
rectangle and you kind of have to you
use the space allotted to you so you can
probably get like five good wipes from
one it's just wasteful to just wipe with
one don't you agree
one wiper if you're using a wet one you
gotta get like good a couple but you
want one wipe does it all I want people
to know this you have to wipe more than
once generally speaking I'd care about
you guys you don't want and wish the
best for you get yours Dell Jesus I
really went on a tangent there all that
and get the blade the butter the
cleanser the wipe and then you keep the
blades coming for a few bucks more a
month get yours at dollarshaveclub.com
slush HD that's dollarshaveclub.com
h3 try those products out I guarantee
you're gonna look at all thank you for
sponsoring a shredder not now shredder
chill out thank you to the block talks
the black tux black tux is a-ok and this
is a great service getting a tux or ax
or suit is an unbelievable nightmare for
anyone it's expensive it's a schlep it's
this whole song and dance that you don't
want to put up with it's ridiculous okay
but the black tux makes it easy for you
and they make it a wonderful beautiful
thing for your next big event whether
you're going for a stylist selected
outfit or building a custom look the
black tux has tons of new suits and
tuxedos to choose from for your big
spring event and with their new fit
algorithm you don't have to awkwardly
measure yourself or ask a friend for
help
hey hey Jim can you measure my crotch
mm-hmm you don't do that anymore
unless you want to the black tux does it
for you they use your height your weight
and other info to predict your size
using their fit algorithm plus the black
tux free home try on lets you see the
fit and feel the quality of your soup
before the event your order will arrive
14 days before your event try it on make
sure it fits if not send it back for
adjustments and remember how simple
returns are where it turns some heads
then send it back three days after the
event shipping is free both ways stand
out at your event for the right reasons
to Jesus don't be like me at Jack's
wedding and show up late and be turning
heads for that reason
turn them for the right reason don't
show up in a Hawaiian shirt turn heads
for the right reasons
with the black tux the black tux is the
easy way for guys to rent suits and
tuxedos online try this you're not going
to regret it get $20 off your purchase
visit the black tux comm slash h3h3
that's the d black tux comm / h 3 HD for
$20 off your purchase the black tux
premium rental suits and tuxedos
delivered right to your gut
flippin dang door thank you to all of
our sponsors guys if you're in the
market please support them because it
makes all this possible
thanks for Wes get back into it we are
back with ninja what up dude let me ask
you this yesin professional gaming a lot
of people have been saying like furl it
feels like a long time like it's
happening it's happening it's happening
it's gonna happen
like it never really happened yes and
never I mean it's never really got to
that place what do you think are the
biggest challenges that face
professional gaming I've always thought
for example the fact that the popular
games are always rotating and so it's
hard to like like baseball it's always
baseball always and so do you think that
there's any is there solution right or
is that just inherent problem of the I
think right no I think that it's gonna
be something definitely that is always
gonna be a hurdle for sure
you look at League of Legends in my
opinion the reason that they're so
successful is the game has been the
exact same minor - some upgrades to the
maps and new champions but I think those
new champions like that like that's this
thing like like a fortnight let's just
say for when it goes eSports right which
I think we you send me that right or no
no rod slash I mean excuse me China some
someone is investing 15 million in in
foreign aid eSports in China like that's
happening based on what you did in Vegas
which we will talk about but sir I mean
that's like oh evidence yes so so let's
just say 496 around you know or creates
that that eSport like the way
a that it needs to evolve is in a very
minimal way so constantly constant like
new skins clearly like maybe like a new
map right but it always needs to be 49
because that make sense same thing with
League of Legends hound League is always
League and the new champions is actually
a spin where it's like okay this is
different it's cooler and you can always
do bigger and better and that's great
and now like the Super Bowl I mean
football those things are always the
same and sometimes the rules change a
little bit here and there right and
that's kind of like how how it should be
sports needs exactly the dude I'm
telling there's a reason that call of
duty and halo are like for lack of a
better word is falling off its and it's
simply just because new games do you
lose you're gonna do to you I'm an h1
fan man halo only dude heee all the way
halo team and all hits you lose you're
gonna lose always a chunk of your
viewers you know it's interesting we've
talked about before about Counter Strike
did the beautiful thing is that the game
was old they re-released it same game
new graphics that was it that was it
right the games and now super popular
yes yes the game was been streaming in
my opinion also really helped it well I
mean in my opinion truly helped it blow
up to where it was solid I mean it was
everything was like the number one
twitch for a while like right after were
League of Legends I think it was the
gambling had a lot of a lot to do with
it as well like the the appeal of cases
and stuff like that definitely helped
and I think that now absolutely after
like a lot of the controversy wouldn't
talk too much about it those people who
did those things really shed it put in a
negative light and I also think that's
kind of where it why it's not exactly
where it should be today
mmm oh for sure yeah you know you know
you know yeah it was really very popular
but dude those gambling scandals have
rocked sports for a long time it's
almost in a way a rite of passage right
they're like oh your gambling scandal
like hey we made it clear yeah but yeah
do you think it's possible to have a
competitive game that's evergreen in the
sense that a traditional sport is not
okay I kind of dark not until like a lot
of older people smell you later
literally because right now the majority
like you're 50 or 40 50 so all those
people they love gambling what are the
gamble they go and they watch football
they watch basketball right and so when
our generation can like right now our
kids are going to leave 100% are growing
up they
what do they want to be do they want to
be the next LeBron some of them but a
lot of them want to be competitive
players professional players and that's
simply because now it's accessible right
it literally didn't exist you didn't
meet you couldn't have a computer 50
years ago right that's true now you do
you had a basketball you're thinking
like 30 what like 20 30 40 years I think
I think less truly because I feel like
with with the technology growing right
now you have the phones right to think
the views are there and when the views
are there the kids are there it's there
so I think honestly I think you're gonna
see a massive jump in the next 5-10
years I'm Justin but but we'll but to
the point where like if eSports and
these companies try to like bring in the
older audiences if they go out of their
way and they do that successfully then
it could be sooner but that's hard I
don't think you can convert I don't know
you think it's impossible it really is
this hard very few parents understand
including mine at the time when I was
starting out they were just always like
you know like okay what do you like
Mehran yep go go play yeah and then you
know I'd be exhausted for 12 hours but
you know still being Charles going to
school and working my job that I had and
that was why that was okay but for a
parent to be like excited about their
kid it's kind of even crazy to think
about a world where they can be like I
want to be a pro gamer and the parent
encouraging that and be like alright you
did you practice today you imagine that
right you play fortnight for eight hours
today how many wins yeah how many wins
you get in China and like Asia like that
side of the world really is like they're
already kind of there right there are
parents who are like they are like you
need to play they want their kids to be
the next person the next up faker
right like because that's their is their
I'm you go there you see there they sell
these massive arenas dude it's insane
the world here was oh my god was it I
don't know well I think was I think was
in Beijing China it was it was some it
was massive dude it literally was like a
they had drum lines and like it was
insane you have to watch the rebroadcast
well-worth the games they were playing
just league of legends dude Oh Lee it
was it was the league is so popular
stuff it's again the four-night formula
the league of legends formula I'm sorry
there might have been someone before Lee
that did it too but Lee is the one that
is the biggest right now besides for
Nate yeah
that formula is working dude
free-to-play in game skins purchases
acts accessible to everyone how you want
to play league oh I don't have the money
man oh it's free
yeah oh and and you can this is
fortnight playable on shitty computers
because that was a power of legally it
really is if you don't as long as it's
not a potato right and as long as you're
not running at the highest graphics
right but still battle Royales are the
biggest struggle including for night is
like that connection the server's right
is like you're some reason it can't even
come close to being like the
counter-strike server or something that
yeah so tell me about your your event in
Vegas that you just finished and you
came here from I when I read about that
I was like this is the cool [ __ ] ever
I'd never seen anything like it
mm-hm so well I don't I don't want to
miss describe it so why don't you tell
us what what was it you were doing in
Vegas last weekend okay man so yeah
Ninja Vegas 18
we just finished a two days ago and it
feels like it was literally like I just
got off it honestly it was insane so we
set up an event it was a we didn't tell
anyone it was it was gonna be a four
night event but everyone kind of knew
and we had 235 tickets I think we're
selling four players to compete it would
be three heats 235 tickets 200 we sold
yet there were a total of 70 so three
heats nine games total 75 players in
each game so so devout so no setups like
yeah at 205 435 and and we sold I think
it was like 400 500 spectator seats or
something like that and it sold out we
didn't expect I didn't expect it really
I just simply just because like I mean
people do someone travel from Mexico
that was cool I mean I had a bunch of
people who were who were like talking to
different accents I'm assuming that they
are obviously maybe someone from Europe
but yeah this guy was I guess you want
to think I came from Mexico bro like
immediately I was like you know got a
picture signed all this stuff but it was
come on man like someone came from
Mexico to a Las Vegas event for for for
fight like for melee it was it was
mind-blowing then we broke the new
Twitter record 600 and my own record of
live this was six hundred eighty
thousand concurrent so so the format was
really was really cool it run me up like
a poker tournament in a way yep where
you had a bounty on your head yep so if
somebody in a game killed you how much
did they get $2,500 to kill me $2,500 to
win the game so right and I got second
place twice so two guys got dollars one
killer
yeah I was so happy man I like seeing
every single person that want I'd look
over in their face they were just you
know ecstatic the crowd their families
in the crowd freaking out so so and was
there what was the barrier to entry was
just first-come first-serve on the
tickets oh yeah we released we I did a
huge hype stream released a date look at
the ticket sales and then we we
originally didn't open up any seats -
spectators whatsoever because we wanted
to make sure that like the players kind
of sold out and then once the players
sold out then we were like okay now
we're all being inspected right we're
any of them really okay I saw I don't
know how many games total we're played
like eight nine so you won one I got the
worst I did was like 30th and it was
like a really unfortunate hike I messed
up yeah really bad and then I got like
top ten like four games five games
second place twice first place and then
all I wanted was one win man I was
honestly like the fact that you won one
game when everybody hundred people 99
people are trying to kill you -
typically you
it is pretty insane it was annoying a
little because the event with the event
was advertised as to me at the time a
ninja event all me all you know and it
was gonna be like just you know fans
fans could play right and it was not
supposed to be competitive by any means
truly and and then we all these oh and
we sell these organizations are like all
these pro orgs right they're like
purchasing tickets for their players and
myth myth comes in he bought he was like
one of the first guys to buy a ticket to
get in and I was just like here we go
it's now yeah every game had very
talented players so did you shut him
down
did you slam dunk on him oh I beat a lot
of good players but I mean dude again it
wasn't even the point really I had a lot
of fun and every fight I had was a very
talented player usually I didn't really
kill too many bad people right so it was
exciting I feel like you have to be good
to pony up and oh yeah to do that
hopefully I mean a lot there were a
couple
there was this one reporter from her
virtue was like just trying to play to
get the experience of it and he he said
he had fun but I don't believe him but
know when you're bad a fortnight
it can oh it's not you kids rough yeah
yeah I guess a good player I mean that's
all that's those are the guys that I box
in a little one by one all right so you
how long were you playing in that event
attitude it was not it was like a seven
hour event so I was pretty exotic
break 5 minute breaks here and there in
between each game I was in my room once
but that was they they want ya because I
wanted to like say hello to everyone so
whenever there was like a small little
commercial break or whatever I was just
out like meeting everyone so are you
planning on doing more like that I feel
like that template could be something
really powerful like for a real
tournament the president of look of like
the hotel and it cut like they were like
went like let's get him back let's do
this again to make this the thing like
and in me like I had so much fun it was
so incredible too it was just a perfect
combination man like I love Vegas right
I love I love gambling here and there
and traveling with my wife is also fun
she loves Vegas too and meeting all
those fans was perfect it was a great
environment and and your fans who were
watching on twitch loved it too he broke
the record that was that something that
the whole thing was game changing right
not only do we break the record but that
was allowed to stream in my channel it's
actually one of the things that they
pushed they were like we want you to be
on your channel and we'll do it on as
well as like multicast but the main
channel is going to be yours and I mean
for a good reason because of the
exposure that I already had from when
and it was easy was a no-brainer it was
so epic mmm cuz that and then they
actually they thought that was what they
wanted to do was what happened which was
the production the high level quality
but what like they thought I might not
be okay with was that they were like
okay like so is it okay if we like don't
have your overlay like your webcam your
alerts your donations I was like you
don't accept any of that get all that
offices that would be weird it was great
they were partners I was esports Arena
yeah they asked us they approached us
they designed it such they were I I
can't like literally I cannot give them
enough shout out to how well they did
they know it was amazing dude and like
the production quality no mistakes they
didn't do I never felt uncomfortable for
a second that's all so it was amazing
that's awesome yeah I mean has there
been a high level tournament was because
that's not prospect of like the hundred
best players mm-hmm in a game together
its it would be so crazy wouldn't it it
would be it all again it has to be solos
almost like
Tour de France yes maybe you play like
10 yeah then the mollify or like yeah
even though so this is with Battle
Royale
and dude no that's that's perfect right
you kind of just you nailed it right
there are a lot of events where there's
one hundred two hundred three hundred
four and five hundred people enter one
guy wins and it's epic right like that
guy is crown for like four years it's
like it's like the World Cup right and
it's like he's best of one the only guy
what's not enough it's not enough to
actually gauge the city level but with
with it with multiple games you add up
and that's that's tough that's that pubs
you started it
that is the eSport like it the only way
truly where that level that layout that
they need a season like how they play
bases in the season they need points
they need like I would be interested in
watching that oh yeah genuinely of
course like if there was a hundred games
over season and right and then it goes
to the championship with a hundred
top-performing the real deal the best
and best thing is and this is what I
hope it's really unfortunate because
squads is for men right and and that's
not that's not the key dude I've been in
I've been in battle rails for a long
time h1z1 and pub G and I solo solos and
duo's it is you you paint you can it's a
little bit slower you can paint a
picture like it's it's super easy to
follow and the and the fights aren't
ridiculous you look at a fight man and
pubsey and four is in the h1 like you
you lose 90% of the action I how good
you are it it would have to be solos is
like the serious bracket yes and then
like Tim's would be just like fun Super
Smash Bros is exactly like that layout
is like no one no one gives a crap about
44 or free-for-all no no one knows about
the 2v2 but thank you she was cool
exactly and like there's a prize pool
there but it's the solos man it's a 1v1
if someone can actually get a
season-long League of that it will be so
big somebody work on that I can promise
you that
oh yeah why don't ya although I mean
they should be they not control their
own they need to be yeah so no but this
was the first event though I like this
with four night and I'm excited yeah man
oh yeah dude there's that you're cool
get in uh it's it's okay you talk you
can talk to game it's fun mix button
it's fun to watch just the whole
building and everything it's just so
weird and wild man I feel like it has
the legs to go all distance oh yeah yeah
it could be I mean I think it's it's
everything yeah it really is I noticed
that all you
social medias you've got at ninja on
Twitter on Instagram on YouTube yep just
got the odd twitch yes I was like how
the hell engine on every social media
how do you accomplish that okay were you
in early brother it was a long haul only
thing I was in earlier was twitch
justin.tv I was ninjas hyper hyper ninja
one of those and cos ninja was taken
obviously and they jaw his nick worked
for justin.tv like reached out to me
after i had you got built a following
streams like a year which was I came in
like one engine and I was like oh cool
yeah and this was before like so right
now there's a name change all that stuff
the integration is super easy to name
change of stuff like that back then
I literally he like the guy hadn't
logged in like two years or some [ __ ]
so they actually he gave me like the log
and essentially I change me but because
he was inactive forever
and and there was like legally they were
within the rights to do that so I got
that and then I had his channel viewers
though like those channel numbers all my
followers all my use gone scratch again
it actually sucked but you know fast
forward five six years later Twitter was
the first thing I got though gene and
John I've reached out three for like
every year forever like every month
leading up to that was like did the guy
was just an active literally an active
every single time but unfortunately I
kept doing it wrong on Twitter I kept
adding him like hey man like please like
I just want like talk to me like I would
love your username like I'll pay I'll do
whatever I don't care like I just talk
to me I wonder what's going on and the
guy never ever responded never followed
back never did anything and then and
every time I mentioned him I would blow
up the person's phone and the person
would log in and check what was going on
and then that was active now he's now
he's active no I have to wait another
six months before I can I can put a
request in to like oh I literally I
literally was shooting myself and so
they they would check in back I don't
give a [ __ ] about this yeah what is then
Twitter be like oh they logged in oh
he's active we can't legally be
interesting so fast forward even more
finally I reached out to Rishi one of
the guys at Twitter and I was like hey
like fun fact is like his name's
available and he was just like dude
literally we came available two days ago
it was like six months and two days
whatever so boom got that fast forward
Instagram was the easiest ever it was
really hard it was when I was already
super popular for and I was
like just you know massive and then I
reached out to my guy brand and also
came in like I would love ninja on
Instagram I reached out I was like I
want to verified and he was like well
what about ninja like let's see I
checked and I don't think there was a
username it was just taken by someone
that never posted there yep that's
fortunate
boom about that and then YouTube was I
needed to have I needed to have 8
million subscribers on YouTube before I
got the route before they would I mean I
think it was like it wasn't a rule but
Winston's yeah they were like cuz the
guy was again the guy was inactive on
with ninja on you tan and they were like
oh by the way like would you like it we
could give it to you I was like yes
that's so crazy what a great one today I
literally everything just fell into
place but I I mean I definitely made
moves and try to and try to make it
happen as much as possible well until
finally I did and I actually do you
think that's a huge it is huge branding
I was blown away I was like what do I
mean it's so far unfortunately with like
halo man I try to get in I tried to do
this for so long and I really just
couldn't because I don't know whether or
not I wasn't popular enough or like that
it wasn't there like we weren't there
yet for them to be like oh yeah we'll
give it to them oh yeah any will verify
I'm yeah that's the coveted username
just ninja straight up dude you got to
get ninja calm where's that at oh I I
actually the it's available I think it's
like I think that's being sold like
thirty thousand dollars something crazy
might be worth it definitely if you can
get that for 30k I think I think it'd
probably be worth a lot more now now
that you've said it everyone's trying to
buy that domain I heard you say in an
interview and it interests me I didn't
know what you meant you had said that
fortnight had made a deal with twitch it
was one of the reasons why your viewers
had had gone up no it was so it was
twitch prime is that what you meant
you're just talking about Twitter Brian
no I totally know that and that was one
of the main things as for when I did do
a deal with Twitter I'm just out like
you know any other game in the past has
done tutorial so Twitter allows people
to I mean hey you guys can click on the
subscribe button and subscribe for free
just yeah see what's there there so it's
they do deals with companies where
they're like hey you know like we want
cool loot they give away every week and
Twitter I'm did something with for night
and now okay so you have so that's when
they pushed it to four nights platform
to sting and then everyone started
logging into twitch and checking out for
night and oh wow I also have a free
which rhymes up as well that's why my
sub counters skyrocket but I was already
doing very well before that in terms of
the viewers I didn't really see too
large of a viewer increase but the
southern creases so you had it so what I
mean what percentage can you I'm not
wanted I couldn't really give but you
saw like an immediate huge boost sub
down the sub count well at the first day
that's great thing about we were it was
a slow growth right we were out like I
think we're at like a hard 40k 50k and
then this came out and we for like the
first week was about ten thousand
subscribers a session whoa scream
session so like the morning my morning
Shane from 9:30 to 3 was ten thousand
subscribers and then the night stream
ten thousand subscribers so like right
now I'm actually kind of on the decline
but I'm I'm like I'm evening out I'm
flatlining in a good way yeah I want to
do stability yes and then because
eventually once those are all gone
essentially because you have to manually
research scribe what's what's wrong yeah
yeah you gotta keep reminding and it's
kind of sell outi yeah but also well
goodness is free it was that free and it
really the advert I don't tell anyone to
sub to my channel and pay me money like
every day hey subscribe give me money no
that's not that's not okay
but Twitter arm is free if you Amazon
Prime you link your Twitter account that
is free
it's literally money just going on like
wasted isn't incredible your mind when I
saw that like I think most of all
streamers and us included women are our
money comes almost or not almost telling
largely from right the twitch prime subs
oh yeah they're just giving it away it
is so the link is where like where they
make the revenue is is obviously they
have deals revenue so it's probably with
like with the Lu with Epic Games I'm
assuming there was some sort of probably
payment sure so they get hooked up they
get the hook up there and everyone gets
it for free and I mean Amazon Prime like
I'm sure that I mean if it push I like I
think I did the math if they sell one
Amazon Prime sign up right membership
was like a hundred dollars a year mm-hmm
that pays for like a hundred you're like
50 B then a Franchi and they probably
even calculated over several years and
then how much money they're going right
or just now there's more oh it's there
it's brilliant they're making so much
the thing is like it's like how much
does it cost to sub five bucks
$4.99 is minimum and then it's 10 bucks
a month for its own it's almost just
makes sense just to get Amazon Prime all
these you people who are subbing the
channels Judy I think it's easy
literally the the shipping alone the
next day shipping or whatever like the
free two-day shipping and and the the
money that you literally saved
everything is cheaper right once you
have Amazon Prime you literally make
your money back within two purchases dan
said keep talking about Amazon Prime
we're getting a hundred subs a second
anyway about Amazon Prime is
unbelievable on that buttons just right
there you could click it scribe I'm free
man don't even need to uh to your
account man through your moms dads
brothers sisters right log in smash them
what is the log in mom I want to support
my favorite reamer for free what that
honey for free I'm alone scares me
though at the same time I know I
shouldn't bite the hand of feedback they
scare me tell me they're massive they're
massive and they keep growing dude I
don't really think that they're doing
anything I mean bad there's no Facebook
right it's not like they're lured no
Jeff Jeff Bezos seems like a decent guy
he seems like a good guy
there was like a story that we were
talking about recently about how their
warehouses are like basically like I
don't want say slave labor because you
could quit the job but like really bad
for working again yeah but I think what
i what i also read is that all
fulfillments right actors are like
that's out there I mean some people I
mean if you want the money like that's
like you're signing up for that you know
you know like what you just said if you
yeah you can leave you can't leave a
sweatshop in China but you can clearly
leave it you can bounce you can quit
like oh you can I don't like this okay
leave okay I can leave thank you yeah
exactly
I'll take that's right that's right but
there was a real interesting article we
were reading that people were like
pissing in bottles and [ __ ] because the
bathroom was on the bottom floor and
it's not worth it apparently they're so
strict on productivity that if you take
a bathroom break
you get anyway you probably he looks
great
he's got a beautiful he's a beautiful
man he's got a great thing there's a
button
dude no they do do you buy pile of [ __ ]
on Amazon is that even a question yeah
you know the Amazon does like they
sometimes you're eligible for free one
day and they'll put it on today and you
have to manually click once they come on
Doug you know I want that one yeah and
we still have a new you people do not
pee
because you're doing that one day yo you
in the warehouse turn this [ __ ] off and
get back to work you son of a [ __ ]
not before you smash subscribe though
and then they do this other thing where
you can click like it's no rush and you
get like a $1 coupon it's like get it
real Amazon I want that [ __ ] right right
now I did that one time when I was like
wow am i good person no yeah it was I
don't think the kindness of your heart
yeah thank you
couple bucks was it really no rush or
were you find yourself regretting that
decision it was still fast
yeah there's there are certain things
option you don't need I need everything
I usually I found mine Amazon I'm
usually there because I want it right
next day they they like ruined shipping
yeah the whole world Oxman but it's also
like I mean I don't know I can you I
don't know the politics about like what
they support and stuff like that but I
mean hopefully there's eventually a day
where there's pressure toward the person
wants to just always do the best and
when you're at Amazon he's probably a no
billionaire if not more like he's a
trillionaire Jeff Bezos million he's the
first truly not sure if you're serious
I'm serious or I don't know if he's
there yet but he's really Dan I don't
know but he's on track to become the
first real what's the what's even the
difference he's nice apparently you guys
20 Billy yeah apparently he all aren't
smashing the sub hard enough honest
which Amazon Prime I've been yeah isn't
that unbelievable I'm pacing back and
forth in my wife all the time and yet
literally I mention her a lot because
she's literally a part of everything I
do I wanted to ask you to next just
piggyback and off that that she's your
manager along have you guys been working
together in a professional setting about
two years like it did it's perfect like
she there's no one's gonna fight for me
more than more than my wife and that's
the thing that I think it's beautiful
like she thinks that you know she thinks
even more of me than I think of myself
and I think that's one of the biggest
things about that but we like one of the
things we always go over is I hit all my
ideas off of her I'm like what about we
bounce back and forth like this this I'm
like what do you like this she's like no
but like you believe it like this it's
good so like we're trying to figure out
like how do we connect like hundred
thousand one hundred No
Amazon right like dude give me like hi I
am like all combined subscribers on
twitch paid and unpaid is less than 1%
of that how do we get people all those
how do we get them excited how do we
even get them over like is it even up to
us can we do anything or is that Amazon
not promoting it because why would they
well I guess Amazon doesn't have much of
an incentive they want it going the
other way that they want the twitch
there they don't want that cost me the
money that's why you can't set it to
auto renew right right I knew that right
away I would just hemorrhage them on
course but be glad to truth be told
though is like they also their I mean
how many people subscribe and then
completely forget about that
subscription and until like two years
three years later sometimes you're like
holy no my bill subscribe the Netflix on
five accounts like whatever and and
that's what and that is why like because
truly there is no reason for it unless
you go out of your way and this is
something that I think that should do is
like they need to be able to have it so
worried like you can turn it on because
one another thing that I do get is like
what if I want to my brothers actually
he budged everything right so like he
makes sure that his twitch prime sub
goes to someone specific that he really
enjoys so he doesn't want to give it to
one person five months in a row like
it's actually a good thing that it
doesn't auto renew but from the guy it's
like oh yeah give me the option to like
click on I want to give me enjoy my
switch for him sub this ones and that
would be insane for streamer it would've
been dude I don't see it happening
I wouldn't everything I wish you would
I'm gonna try to have a twitch if you're
listening Jeff you're out there just for
me please or anyone I love for I mean
for everyone but I'm listening
amen dude help me what do you think I
want to ask you you you've been working
with your wife for two years yes but you
guys been together for like six so was
it at what point were you like hey maybe
we should work together professionally I
think it was you know she worked the job
she got a college I was like a
recruiting agency she was not having a
lot of fun they were treating her really
poorly to be honest they were like you
know her job was to you know go flat dry
five minutes and work at this office and
every day they're like making her go 45
minutes to another office and this is
only one even we were dating still but
we weren't living together she was a
four hours away and I was just like get
over here like that's garbage I can take
care of you like and then so she she
started up and she was streaming as well
at the time too so making decent money
not enough to like quit
alone right but she moved in she started
streaming within like two months she
started making the same amount revenue
from streaming she different that job so
that and she's happy
just great cool and then I think when it
I think it started making sense around
h1z1 h1z1 is when was when I started
getting a lot of emails that I would
literally answer in the middle of my
stream and then too much Toria
then she's just like it was natural I
got that easy so she started ah that's
so cool yeah and then like again like if
anything could just makes her stronger
we have its we have continued reasons to
keep our communication upgrade and
that's the most important thing in a
relationship is just being able to talk
to one another and damn that's good it's
great how it happened naturally yeah I
was like hey listen yeah I don't know I
don't know how that happens sometimes
but no yeah she was eager she would love
to she was like of course I'd love to be
able to go to bat for you and get and
get us paid absolutely that's super cool
yeah man god bless thank you sir I mean
she's beyond manager absolutely that's
management of a different kind
yeah I have a bad day when we get those
courts it's off yeah we just moved to
new house it has every day I haven't I
haven't used it to squirt water up my
ass you need to but like theoretically I
don't understand I feel like I will uh
[ __ ] all of you so it's a small stream
it's a small very high pressure it feels
like good and it literally just just
cleans it out and one way ok you don't
do little you don't do anything what do
you do afterwards you just want one to
get the wall you book you can't apply
toilet paper it's not that your but you
know it's not like it sprays all over
your but like everybody tell about my
life I have a hairy [ __ ] well I'm
just saying you shave that a little bit
you shaved the [ __ ] just kind of like
how like when the kids are legs right I
mean I'm scared to shove a razor um you
don't get that's right interesting this
is this is on your stream not mine no
that's good these are the details
I want let me just say it's not part of
my job as your carrot oh yeah I need you
oh that would solve that was so the
issue because I when I go and wet a
clump oh brother of course bad no it's
bad that's why that's why well apps are
huge so if I have like a tight clean
sweet little anus then I could probably
use a bidet what does that mean that
French people are all maintaining their
[ __ ] I think that that's because
they actually don't shave their armpits
like that's like a face that's the
[ __ ] keeping it nice and clean dude
damn the Ninja shaves his [ __ ]
respect speaking of [ __ ]
yes Jake Paul I want to ask you about
sure that's a great so i he's got this
like legendary clickbait story i
he changed the thumbnail but originally
had like a picture of did it's a ninja
and had a picture of you so I I was very
I didn't want to reach out to him about
it because why because no because why
and it was something that I not died
stray away from all sorts of drama like
that and don't want to give anyone a
story like off of me like that but yeah
don't eat I mean dude I would love to
have a conversation and truly with him
like in person about what what was going
through his mind when like hey donated
ten thousand or $30,000 to my favorite
twitch streamer wasn't it two hundred
times it was two hundred was always crop
low so you're right I'm sorry it was it
was two hundred thousand and and like
not only was I never even mention in the
video it wasn't to me it was the most it
was the hands-down the one of the most
click babies in my entire life it's not
it doesn't that's maximum clickbait that
is the death topic you can literally
didn't even mention you nope I don't
know anything I listened to the whole
thing I was and it's like me 20 minutes
I miss it didn't hear once and then I
was just like oh how the [ __ ] is you I
don't know how YouTube didn't like
remove that video because we reach out
to them and it's like dude it's so dumb
YouTube is so corporate like you're like
I like whether or not I have you know
all the subs that I've have and how
quickly I'm getting them it's irrelevant
I'm a
and I have to go through the I mean and
they take they reach out to me I've
contacted a lot of them but I have to
have my editor or me we have to go
through we have to report every single
video we have to same we have to then
upload proof that it is my video and
then like and then when it comes to the
thumbnail there's a certain way you
report someone using your thumb you
probably have a lot of copyright issues
on on YouTube as well it's all relative
idea we have we're and now we're not
we're working on striking large channels
and like you do I let everyone know I'm
like you're gonna rip don't [ __ ] with it
don't know it seriously if you're gonna
rip my content like completely like
someone makes a highlight video
highlight like full-blown cool highlight
clips add edits it creates it it's kind
of like on any Food Show whatsoever
whether like chops is perfect right
we're gonna give you these onions and
this and this and you don't just take
the onions chop them up and you put it
on the plate like you have to create it
yeah yeah very good point I I'm okay
with like some wants to do some God to
your career we created a ninja montage
person like that I will never strike
that down but if it's literally just a
theory of what it's like you're an ear
piece of [ __ ] like you are and we better
that's the bottom that's how we started
on our podcast highlight channel because
oh yeah we have a podcast highlight
channel that's like gotten pretty
popular and it was born from people just
ripping off and they were getting like
millions of views and were like whoa
really popular videos that are coming
out it's like that are having like two
three Miller's like that now we're just
we're just taking the revenue from it
we're just reaching a claim in yep yeah
why not fine why not it's your property
it's also it's like uh a certain point
when it is getting a lot of views and as
long as it's not negative read there are
some people who actually try to like
make these dumb fake thumbnails and like
clickbait thumbnails right and try to
show me in a negative light and those
are the ones we try to take down because
that's my exact opposite of what about
like not even kind of slandering me a
little bit and that's not okay oh [ __ ]
oh yeah you you you you come from twitch
right and so it's funny to hear you
talking about YouTube of like how
corporate and dissident they are because
we've all all of us people who started
on YouTube I've been doing that with
that forever and it's funny that you got
that impression from just you interact
it takes note it takes know I mean yeah
they don't witches look they're so
interactive so
hands-on hello I mean yeah you look at
you tubing that is vitamins but again
you should kind of is literally like
they just came over to TV right there
there it's a behemoth it's massive its
massive it's way bigger than twitch
right yeah and even though amazon has
twitch it's still in my opinion is like
right now youtube like everyone and
their grandmother knows about YouTube
everyone everyone it is and that is
where I find really that's Wirt
Winchester I feel also the twitch staff
and the people who work there actually
watch tweet streams and they like know
what's going on twitch we're on YouTube
the people work at YouTube don't watch
youtuber this is probably what's
unfortunate our experience at least yeah
there's like they don't know they don't
care cuz they're like court they come
from they mostly work for YouTube come
from Google right they just transfer
them over and like where they're
supposed to just automatically into
their like yeah I mean like no just all
about the numbers and the algorithm and
that they're just engineers of algorithm
I'd love to talk about how the fact that
like you know why any video is ever
featured ever on YouTube about me when
it is my gameplay and when it's not from
me I would love to know why that so many
so many I have so many people who are
popular I mean even like syndicate
sometimes like tweeted and just like why
is this in my featured tab and it's like
a video my gameplay someone else welcome
to YouTube it right where I and that's
what I have to go and take it down dude
there are live streams of live streams
ripped live streams of my twitch up
being like with 15,000 viewers on
YouTube where there's a donation button
to that guys don't they're restreaming I
guess what I have to go and report it
did the live stream and provide proof
that it's me man yeah and even my editor
doesn't have time to like constantly
lose a live stream it's like I gotta go
and rip 50 60 70 you almost need to hire
someone just to like the only pet we pay
him and it's still like I still feel
like sometimes it's like yes too much a
lot yeah but that used to happen to us
to where someone would reap off for a
stream right away and upload a clip and
then before they uploaded it first
before us they would get promoted the
algorithm promote shares as recognizes
there says the original once we upload
ours then hit those get those it's not
on it's unacceptable it's really it's
just it's just the the beast that it is
I think what happens is it can be
stopped though that's why it's all
numbers for them so if someone reads a
video it's just it's cold
guess all they care about is watch time
and how many people clicked it any ads
or how long they wash I think it's all
about that and then that has come in
secondary right you're right so if
there's a video and people are clicking
it and watching it they're gonna show it
to everybody
mm-hmm for whatever reason I mean again
and I want to I want to stress this as
well like I know a lot of people who are
at YouTube who are like helping me out
and trying to like get ya act and make
sure everything is going well so like
it's not like they're not doing anything
but it don't really help in that
capacity though right try if you don't
they just don't correct and not because
I again they don't have to yeah cuz
there are those avenues that if oh if
you want to take him down then he will
go out of his way to get it taken down
and that's like okay it's your
responsibility then yep
the thing is that YouTube has been
through so much legal
oh my can't even imagine that I clearly
why I think it's a legal issue 100% it
is of course I think I'm pretty sure
yeah you need to accept the liability
you need to like sign off and say you
know it's it's all me like it's like I I
am providing proof and I am saying that
this is my content making sense if I
consent yeah and if there's like a
penalty or some [ __ ] like then like
YouTube is just like one me like he
applied it made sense we did remove it
and like yeah it wasn't enough proof but
like yeah yeah it's different
yeah it is different but it's still also
extremely annoying okay
you can't be on YouTube and not love
hate it it's impossible yeah I've never
met someone who's just like I love you -
I love everything about it
you can do that on Twitch somehow it's
which is beautiful man it's a great
beautiful day it really is and I don't I
don't again I don't I don't see that
changing ever what do you think about
people like Jake and Logan Paul coming
on Twitch and playing for tonight
because it almost seems like I mean I
can't get in their heads but it seems
like they're riding off off of your wave
I wouldn't even say you know it's my way
I think they're very competent they
understand what's popular and what's not
that's it
of course not steel they're riding the
wave of what's popular I know and
there's all the sudden it's all like
fortnight and [ __ ] and every of that or
so and they're like oh we got this right
like you know we got this we and and
what a lot of youtubers not just them
are actually seeing is like the
transition over it just not not is it
not you know so like the different skill
it was Logan's first string was like
hundred thousand viewers right for for
like a little bit and then obviously
started to dip and now it's like it's
not doing the greatest and rigorous
numbers oh the last time I checked I was
like I think he was like 6000 or 7000
euros there and like so good to go from
200 I was in your first one I think
everyone was super hyped about to be
tweeted about it YouTube everyone was
like coming over his fans boom you have
it's a difference like Logan pulls his
vlogs are so highly edited and then I'll
study necessary energy live and you have
to be good at the game so to be
entertaining I'll do trust me I love
this [ __ ] okay there are youtubers okay
you didn't bark either there I think
that I think hopefully do treat which is
really kind of I want to say that what
exposing but it really is shows you who
like who it you cannot be fake 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 hours not possible right like it's
super taxing so you see almost literally
dude have you ever ever ever ever ever
seen a youtuber ever have a video that
didn't start with what's going on guys
welcome to the YouTube video here we are
in it's like a 9 10 minute video cut cut
cut cut every 5 seconds yo what's up
guys it's me and it's like and now you
go on Twitch and everyone who's coming
over from that it's a guy sitting there
they're like either like here we go here
we go it's a different skill yes of
course in a different scale to different
experience and it's not enough when
you're playing for tonight and you
expect that many people to watch you
have to be good at the game uni and that
takes a lot of practice so this is
something that I say a lot to a lot of
people is being entertaining and not
skilled is freaking hard shot the CD and
the third by the way because he's one
he's one of the guys who does it he is
decent at the game honestly I would say
that when he's trying his ass off he's
actually very good but he his stream is
doing very well very successful and he's
just funny he's funny he's got he's got
super cool edits and stuff like that is
cool stuff with this camera it's boys
changing it's very good stream and but
that is mainly entertainment that is a
bond comedy like that's where his like
bread and butter is but if you're
skilled man it is like because now
you're gonna get people who you can't
wash yeah it's just weak no you it's
just what you said right like
entertain it's a double-edged
entertainment right it's like people are
like not only is he fun to watch when
he's not on he's good
yes exactly exactly like doing it's like
I've tried to stream like pubs you know
that and like well I can try so hard to
be entertaining and and that's okay for
some people but I suck so bad at the
game that anyone who's popping in and
being like oh what's this guy up to
don't like this guy sucks dick why am I
gonna watch him and I don't blame them
at all right no you can't I mean you
really can't right it's like unless I
agree I suck watch me play funny was
like that's another thing to like
sometimes and this is like not
egotistical but like I'll watch like my
videos are over I'll like literally sit
back could actually watch an entire
video oh my god because sometimes do
when I'm doing it I stream so long I
actually forget sure things I said it
stuff like that so yeah watching like
and if you can't enjoy yourself no one
else is gonna enjoy that either no I see
what you mean I'll go back and watch our
old like even our new videos it's funny
I almost don't watch it for the first
time until it's done and when it's on
YouTube I'll watch it a couple times
take it and be like oh yeah I see what
you can improve on and stuff boys that's
that that's literally what I do yeah I
think it's the only time I can enjoy
watching is when I'm done I'm like okay
I wasn't that bad sometimes I'm like
that was awful I can delete my channel
that's what the fancy what I have a
question about twitch as a platform sure
I feel like twitch has an inherent
challenge that I don't know how they're
gonna overcome okay on youtube you can
do collabs with people you can have all
these different channels and they
there's enough the world is wide enough
for everyone and that you can go watch
someone's video and then go watch
someone's video and go watch someone's
wheel but when you're streaming live you
can only watch one person at a time
right I see that it's like the biggest
hurdle I don't know how they address
that and it almost seems like a ceiling
in a way because when you I mean no
you're angry I don't know but I
definitely I definitely I definitely
agree
being able to I mean here's a here's the
best part is like the and this is why
YouTube is actually successful probably
right yeah he's like you can have three
four five videos up for five tabs up
pause one video that has you know three
minutes left in a video and then start
watching something else just like that
or pause the video do some research like
let's say you're watching a video and
then say you know this guy's hanging out
this
but you never heard of the celebrity
pause the video you go in google it now
you decelerate boom alright you haven't
missed any content yeah so that's like
the beauty of YouTube but the beauty of
twitch is that every single stream like
I mean not a lot of youtubers even
popular ones upload every day it's hard
it's difficult like the video twitches
is like when this is something that
youtube doesn't have unless you are
literally working not many not unless
you are working your ass off making
these great videos every day there's
some but not many right exactly and
that's what that's that is the video
social I think that actually make do the
ceiling where is always something to put
like in a way it is like it's
interacting right and the vaad is there
if you care yep and there are people
that watch and love the pods all the
time and like I have I have people who
will donate or something like five
minutes into my stream hey man just
finished watching your vada in your live
let's go like you just watched that last
six hour stream awesome
all right let's mean it is exactly like
back before H all this ate what do you
call it like when you save television
yeah
DVR is it but like TiVo before that you
vote there ya go was the first that was
go on and then they like changed
everything but before that if you missed
a [ __ ] show you missed L was it you
know so it's interesting to see that
kind of format like reoccurring in a new
and a new age definitely but better
obviously
absolutely yeah that's cool that's a
good answer thank you who do you what do
you say we touched on it briefly about
like these days the kids who are coming
up they want to be they were there
watching you and they want to be
professional players what is it that you
think they should know what is it what
kind of advice would you give them it's
more information than advice but it's
also a little bit both I mean it's not
easy it's like it's the same thing where
is a parent's job to obviously promote
and support their kids dreams but what's
the point of it like what does a dream a
dream is something that is like it's
almost unattainable truly I mean like
you see definition right but it is like
it's like when you're there it's like oh
you've woken up and like oh my god it's
actually happening so I think that's
super important for people to understand
that it is not easy not everyone can do
it and that should also give them more
respect for the people that they do
enjoy and that do have that platform and
are you hopefully obviously doing good
with it but my advice then would be like
if do you want it right like work your
ass off like hard every single day you
have to be and I think I tell them you
have to be better
millions of people meant to hit the
certain level that you are dreaming of
and like I mean dude I gave up
friendships I ruined relationships i you
know completely cut my family out I'm
not not cut them out of my life
but dude like I'd be in the basement
playing video games keep like training
for Halo matches and Halo tournaments
and stuff like that
and we'd have family and friends over
and my brothers would come downstairs my
parents commissars like hey like
everyone's here and I'm just like cool
okay like I don't care like I'm I'm like
I'm practicing my team or I'm playing
and like it's sacrifices and a lot of
cool and but also something that I did
is like I was still going to school I
was still working to get my parents
acceptance right and I'm still doing
well in school so it's a dude it's it's
tough as [ __ ] man yeah and like I and
until until this becomes even like
global I'm talking like everyone wants
to do it and there are you know like
let's just say twitch is the NBA right
and there's like then there's like the
the college basketball section right so
then you can get here but still not make
it to here but still be successful here
and that's okay and then there's like
you know how the NFL has like other like
little and like we're at least like
those are attainable too and so you can
make a living off of until that happens
for twitch and gaming and entertainment
which it isn't there right now then like
I don't think parents ever should be
okay with kids not doing well I mean in
school you literally look at you know
professional athletes what is like the
the typical oh they're flunking in
college I mean in every movie in every
show you know the star quarterback is
flunking but he's literally a god and
he's gonna go to and he's gonna make
millions of money and but he's still not
doing well in school think that won't be
okay it never should be okay but that
won't be even close to being accepted
Brazil so but the interesting thing
about that route too is that they're
doing it through school school yeah
getting scholarships I wonder if that
whatever it's already happening Wow some
colleges are accepting people for like
league of legends in there and there
should be a thing it is holy be today I
mean for Knights doing I'm doing
something with id Tech hashtag plug real
quick let's just IT tech comm such for
tonight and literally it is school it is
coding you go there and like they're
doing something cool with four night and
the Unreal Engine and that should be a
thing that is goal [ __ ] professional
gaming and and professional gaming
programming like literally everything
about it super cool wow that is awesome
yeah I'm sorry I'm just I'm just excited
to it's awesome
finally oh my god I have one question
left for you sure this we ask of alright
guess it's a weird question so if you
don't have a store
if you have nothing to share don't feel
bad I don't either it's customary for
whatever reason that we asked our guests
you have any ghost stories paranormal
experiences or unexplainable things that
happen in your life dude okay so this is
something that I have a couple I think
one of them ice one of them was just was
gone my wife was gone she was in Florida
I think with her friend with her
girlfriend but she loves to hang out and
I was with the dogs
I was alone just finished streaming went
upstairs and I'm like okay I'm gonna
turn off all the electronics like
everything went upstairs had the dogs in
bed and like when one of us has gone
like they're super sensitive to like a
lot of like sounds and stuff but it's
also super sensitive when music starts
playing in the middle of nowhere
downstairs on our speakers mmm what
happened I'm home alone I'm already
freaked out right and I remember I start
hearing a song that had never heard of
that's just playing on my speakers and
why turn everything off what the hell is
this I go downstairs I'm checking my
phone to making sure I've all my
Bluetooth off I'm going downstairs my
computer making sure somehow that's it
so I literally like I've shat my pants
man I'm like I have a katana do you know
turned it off so what was it you just
turn off the I just turn off that I just
turned off the sound system again
I already did before I went to bed huh
it was loud because that is a place here
and now mm-hmm
has a ten-cent has Neven since and then
you Jess has just actually I think she
has to shoot dude she's all about that
[ __ ] she's really I think one of the
creepy one of the creepiest things that
ever happened to me was like it was more
like a like a demon thing weird thing
like the the our the whatever it's
called the witching the witching hour
well I really I'm I woke up on time and
I didn't like smell burning I smelled
something [ __ ] weird now and I woke
up on the dot at 3 o'clock and it was
after I already watched like a movie and
I literally never felt more scared in my
life like someone was watching me
someone was staring I'm and I stayed
awake for like 3 hours straight
oh god it was it was forged up I like he
was the most insane thing in the world
oh here's the story as well so it didn't
happen to me but my wife's friend her
name is Morgan she literally has a
cousin or someone who stayed in a house
and 1 million it was like legit like 1
million percent like there was like a
spirit there
he had a name they talked all the time
and the and she said that the never felt
threatened unless her husband was home
and when her husband was home so we were
something that like the spirit was like
dude it was like the mail and so like
when the husband slept like in the room
he was like dude he like he could never
sleep in the in their house and they
moved that and I end up having to move
but uh there would be on explain
activities who would literally talk to
him and be like and like with Morgan
like there and be like hey like yo
what's up Frank or some like that can
you like open the blinds and the blacks
like shudder like should you know man
well dude I literally I was freaked out
for like a week because from the story
yeah the story alone cuz because it
would choose that she swore she swore
like honor like well they move so yeah
fast well how many times before that
stereo keeps popping on til you bounce
one more one more time that's it I'm out
yeah not the question good I don't [ __ ]
it that like my dad was in college using
a paper on like it was like possession
and stuff like that and it was one of
those papers where his professor said
once you pick your topic you're done
like that's it you have to do it and he
literally started and said as he started
to read into the Laura possession didn't
even says stuff like that that he felt
that stuff like around him and like oh
he was kind of like it's like it's like
a gate right you open you start now if
you like I'm more aware you become more
aware you're opening yourself you're
believing you know it is possible yeah
and so he really went to professor and
was like I will literally fail this if
you don't switch like I can't do it like
he's like it wasn't able to sleep he was
having nightmares and he was - what was
he studying in school it wasn't studying
it was just a pro it was just literally
just a paper like a research paper oh so
it wasn't like he was like studying that
no it was simply just like you which is
like great I'll pick this topic that
stuff you have to you to you but most
importantly do you use a katana for home
defense is it that cold steel there's
company cause no I know my my one of my
moderators got it for me
oh that's like he was like my longest
time I use it like seven years he was
something like seven years he came over
and visited and brought it and those
gifted oh yeah awesome well thanks man
of course had a lot of fun this is all
she was really a beautiful wonderful
time
really enjoy Spain with you and I
appreciate you click on thank you got
super cool thank you guys thank you for
watching
god bless you there there there inside
that little lens there or that one we
are coming back next Friday with the
boys Jack and Eric so stay tuned for
that in a week you'd have to stay tuned
you just stick around yeah hey guys you
got your computer and come back anyway
guys what is today it's Monday so you
should get some Friday like have a great
weekend bye ma'am no no it's usually on
Friday but obviously people have course
yeah yeah no schedule which is happy
that you made the time yeah thank you so
much the other cool start all this is
how you start off the week the right way
absolutely it's been a blast so guys
have a great week and when the weekend
comes around I hope you have a great
weekend then - alright see you guys next
time bye bye bye